something's gone
very wrong in the fabric of american
society which
leaves people vulnerable to the appeal
of
the political hate industry hi my name
is david smick and i'm the writer
director
of the film stars and strife the academy
has always been at the forefront
of political and social issues and i
don't think there is a
more timely film given the recent
presidential election in fact the
election confirms
everything said in the film that america
is divided pretty evenly divided
but that the public seems to not trust
either party for very long
americans are also saying that we want
our leaders
to stop the hate show in washington we
want them to start solving problems
we're tired of the dysfunction we want
our leaders to start to put
country before party that's the powerful
message of the movie and that was the
message of the election
a time to build a time to reap and a
time to sow
and a time to heal this is the time to
heal in america
so i wanted to reach people with this
kind of common sense message of
let's stop the hate it doesn't mean we
have to agree on everything but this was
a nation that was
founded on compromise and compromise is
essential
for us to survive so i went to
some of the top documentary filmmakers
in the country
and i said i want to do a documentary
on hate and dysfunction and the collapse
of empathy
in american life and politics i want to
know how we got here
and how we get out of this mess and
everybody turn me down
and then i went to a fellow baltimorean
barry levinson who also grew up in a
working-class section of baltimore and
then i said
can you recommend someone who could do
this film
and his response was look you should do
the film you've
you have written two new york times
bestsellers you obviously know how to
tell a story
he right from the beginning said this
should be a full-length film
because this this subject is just too
too important i went at it saying
okay i'm going to deal with the
complexity of the answer and of the
dilemma
so how do you do that in a documentary
film
without putting people to sleep
we did a cut of the film i went back to
to barry levinson and barry looked at it
and said this is very compelling
and he made some editorial suggestions
and we had a screening by the way
on the first cut of the film in in
hollywood 55 or so producers and
and directors the response to the
screening was good
but they said we think you need one
change one big change
and i said what is that and they said
you david smith should be
the narrator and the common thread and
you should tell on the film
something about your background and
where you're going and i said well
that's not my style i'm a behind the
scenes strategic advisor and they said
no you should be
you should tell that story and so
that's kind of how the film got to be
where it is so when i began the film i
had a fundamental question of style
we need to explain things but how do you
do that without being deadly
and it just dawned on me let's connect
humor to animation
to explain a lot of these issues
and also it was a question of what kind
of background visuals
because we're going to have millennial
viewers but we're also going to have
baby boomer
viewers and then people are you know
younger than millennials
so what would they identify with and it
dawned on me that
that we would use humor from 1920 silent
films
that that that humor could be
appreciated by
people of all ages
we're living in an age where we have an
entire generation
growing up that doesn't have a clue
about the role of compromise
in effective governing and so when i
decided who should be in this film i
began looking at people
that i had long admired having been in
washington for 40 years
who were effective at compromise leon
panetta
secretary of defense in the obama
administration was just a master
at compromising at times putting country
before party
james baker did the same on the
republican side
i went back and i said how did we get
voting rights how do we get
civil rights compromise you had
republican liberals from the northeast
meeting with democrats to
get around the southern democratic
resistance to
civil rights and voting rights that's
how it happened this country doesn't
move forward
unless both sides can come together
that's the kind of thing
i said we've got to explore in this film
and so i'm going to go to those people
who have these unusual experiences with
and can explain that to the rest of the
country
picking the cast was a very very
sensitive
process because there are a lot of
people who
privately would say to me what you're
doing is wonderful but i can't do it
because i'm afraid that i'm going to be
attacked because
what you're saying is that both parties
are at fault both parties have been
playing the hate game
trying to gain power and money and they
haven't been putting the country ahead
so
i'd love to participate but i can't on
the other hand i have a lot of people
who came along and said i'm in
people say to me how did you get hawk
newsome to be part of your film he's
the leader of black lives matter greater
new york
and the way i did it i just went up and
saw him in the bronx
i said can we can we have breakfast
together
you know a wall street strategist
you know new filmmaker sits down with
this
guy who comes in he's looked about 6'5
with a motorcycle jacket with
with the black lives matter t-shirt and
we sat down
within five ten minutes as hawk would
say
it was like we had a commonality we
didn't agree with everything but on the
same wavelength
he was telling me about his experiences
with police brutality and he was telling
me about a woman who works for him whose
husband had been
at one of the riots and begged because
he was being suffocated and the idea
it's 100 degrees in
the back of a police car handcuffed you
can't get out and they're not letting
you breathe you're not letting you get
out
and then you know a year later i'm
seeing the coverage of george floyd and
i was struck
it was a trend and i think that hawke
newsome probably utters the most
important
one-liner in the film he says
things have been rough for black
americans
he said america beats the crap out of us
but we still love our country i wanted
people to hear that
because just because you protest i would
peaceful protest
but just because you're a protester
doesn't mean you hate your country it
means
you actually want your country to get
better there has been this
effort to take anyone who's involved in
the social justice
reform effort to paint them as america
haters now there are some who are
american haters and they think the
country is inherently evil
it can never reform or whatever and i
thought it was unfair one
particular network you know tried to
smear hawk as
as kind of a violent monster well if you
meet hawke or if you see him
in the film you say this is a good guy
who's trying to come to terms with
the injustice in a system that he sees
needs to be fixed
well i had read about derrick black who
was the heir apparent to the white
nationalist movement
you know part of the whole kkk white
nationalist
message and now backed off and done a
u-turn from the very early period
in his life he's fed this kind of mental
poison
what made him do the turnaround he said
you know
you change people not by
feeding them arguments you change them
by
changing their community and he said so
here i am secretly the heir apparent to
a white nationalist movement in a
college
where the guy next door is jewish
and my best friend is from south america
and my whole family
religion was they didn't belong in this
country
people asked me how did you gain access
to all these people how did you convince
them to be in the film what did you do
when you were turned down
well i was turned down quite often i
just kept going back
you just have to push and you push and
the more you push
the more people say okay
this is important and so i'll i'll do it
the editorial process is very
interesting because you're dealing with
a lot of data a lot of input
it really gets down to trust can people
who have agreed to be interviewed
can they trust you that you will not
manipulate
their views barry levinson and during
one of his uh
you know times watching the film he said
you know
there are no cheap shots i think that is
why this
film resonates stars and stripes was was
very challenging because in the middle
of filming we had a pandemic
and which kind of changed everything
as i adjusted the film to reflect the
pandemic which was
a challenge but i thought we did it
artfully the idea was
to have a film that would appear
just before and then be part of the
discussion
after the election and the election
would be a rude and bold
statement essentially the country's
divided and if we're not careful
we're going to go into a civil war of
some sort
and that this film is is a stand that
says
we don't need to do that and as someone
who's involved in
for the financial markets from the
highest level i can tell you
that how we are perceived is going to
affect things like the strength of the
dollar it's going to affect the ability
of
and willingness of people overseas to
finance our debt there are a lot of big
issues here that politicians don't think
about
when they spew hate back and forth but
basically can
set the terms for a much weaker economy
decades from now i'm often asked why
doesn't the film
center itself around donald trump and
that's uh
we avoid trump for a particular reason
trump is the master
of the mud pit and he says come into my
mud pit
make it all about me and i said
what if we did a film that doesn't
mention trump
which of course he will hate the most
and think about these issues from the
standpoint of america's long-term future
when i first mentioned that to leon
panetta he said i'm sick of talking
about trump let's talk about bigger
things
mistakes in the economy and mistakes in
the political system
i wanted the film to look at things like
economic humiliation
when i was 14 our house burned down
i was living in baltimore and my parents
didn't have a lot of money
and i lost everything
it dawned on me that change is the one
constant
you cannot assume anything about the
future
and i want the viewer to concentrate on
a visual
that occurs early on the bowel of a ship
a ship
turning over and there's a bell of a
ship it looks like the hindenburg
and people are scrambling on the bottom
of the ship just to survive and my point
was
people never see change until it comes
they never expect it and then it comes
and it's blunt
and it's vicious and it's
life-threatening we assume this country
can take
all kinds of abuse we can do anything we
want and things will stay the same we'll
always be successful
always be have a good economy we'll
always be safe
the one thing that i would hope that
someone from the academy who's watching
this film the one thing they come away
with
is that guy makes a point there's a
sense of urgency right now
that change is inevitable and we may not
like the change
that we're going to face and that's why
we need to
join together and have a serious
discussion about america's future